incoming time flex now I have universe
is a complex piece of machinery and
balance must be maintained one change
requires another how would you propose I
keep the balance will you help me save
Barry and Cara or not no but I will give
you the means to save them tell me what
you need in exchange whatever the
multiverse requires to survive the
crisis that is looming
when it is time it's okay
[Music]
so it barked and Mme what does the
multiverse require you assist me as we
seek to prevent the inevitable that that
sounds impossible the multiverse is more
complex than you could fathom what are
you not telling me I've seen your future
Oliver and eggs were more than
unavoidable I have watched you die
during this crisis I am truly sorry
No
you are not taking oh I'm not here to
bring harm to you or your daughter
trust me the world needs her do you
think that I'm just gonna be here with
my husband sigh this is bigger than us
10 all of us I cannot pretend his
passing but he can prevent the death of
countless more easily you and your
daughter but he needs to come with me
tonight
hi everyone its charlie so we got to
talk about the flash season 6 teaser all
the post-credits scenes for crisis on
Infinite Earths on all the air / shows
arrow season 7 finale the legends finale
the Supergirl finale so the odds that
you watch every single one of these
shows is pretty low there's actually a
pretty small audience that just watches
everything you may just watch 1 or 2 of
the TV shows so I'll explain everything
that's going on and how they're gonna do
the crossover this year it's gonna be 5
parts instead of doing 3 or 4 parts like
they've done in previous seasons so it's
gonna be way bigger and they're breaking
it into two different parts one will
start in December like the normal
crossovers do and then the second part
will be in January when all the shows
come back and it's all about the end of
arrow arrows final season so obviously
we're all expecting Oliver to be the one
to die instead of Barry because of this
bargain that he made with the monitor
and they gets into the arrow post-credit
scene I didn't include everything from
the arrow scene so I'll explain the
Felicity part of that too at the very
end of the episode but if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the DC easter-egg videos there's
gonna be a bunch of big stuff coming
this fall we have Batman Deathstroke
ravager and Superboy coming to Titan so
there's a bunch of DC Universe stuff
happening separately but that's all
separate universe from the air / stuff
we'll do a new round of the giveaway for
the DC Universe subscription all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about one of the
crisis episodes on the video side note -
I've already seen the first episode of
Swamp Thing I'm allowed to do a
non-spoilery video this Friday so we'll
be talking about Swamp Thing later this
week first big scene the flash season 6
post credits scenes so obviously they
changed the timeline reverse-flash got
Nora to make a whole bunch of changes
erasing herself but allowing him to
escape from prison he tells Barry see
you at the next crisis because he's from
the future he knows how flash vanishes
in crisis on Infinite Earths but he
might not know about every single change
that just happened so the wrench in his
plan might have something to do with
what Oliver is doing with the monitor
that's sort of the new thing that's
throwing a wrinkle into all this but in
present day the only thing that has
changed about Crysis is that the future
newspaper date has rolled back to the
date of this year's crossover it's still
happening during 2019
so whoever vanishes arrow or the flash
still
happens at the end of this year you know
what that probably means there's gonna
be a huge cliffhanger one of the heroes
will die during the big third act climax
then they'll have an epilogue probably
for Oliver when the second part comes
back in January don't forget - there's
only 10 episodes in the final season of
arrow and it sounds like based on the
monitor grabbing him saying that the
multiverse needs you right now
we need to start right now that all of
the episodes of arrow season 8 will be
crisis episodes if you have not been
watching arrow they've been doing
flash-forwards this year with a future
version of Roy a future version of the
heroes Oliver's daughter in connor hawke
who sort of like the future team arrow
will probably get more of them coming
back - so we'll just be crisis on
Infinite Earths they'll find a way to
sort of tease what happens before it
actually happens using those flash
forwards during the arrow finale
post-credits scene Oliver is sitting
there after his baby Mia has been born
the monitor shows up this is a couple
months after the end of the events of
the arrow finale they dealt with that in
the first half of the episode then the
second half of the episode was all this
crisis stuff that they were setting up
he shows up and says we need to go right
now dude multiverses falling down all
over the place that bargain you made
yeah we need to do whatever the
multiverse requires so he doesn't say
exactly what Oliver needs to do but but
I think it's implied ultimately it will
mean him sacrificing his life so that
Barry and Cara can live they even did
the flashback to show you a longer
version of that bargain scene that he
made during last year's crossover so
that's happening in present day so while
the present day of flash season six and
all the other shows are happening they
have the regular plots Oliver will be
off traversing the multiverse doing all
of his stuff trying to get ready for
crisis there was another scene with the
monitor in an old version of felicity in
the future that I did not include in
this video so what happens is is that
after they sort of saved this city in
the future the future team arrow has
officially taken over for original team
arrow Felicity says goodbye to her
children - Mia natural born daughter
into William her stepson they meet at
Oliver's grave then she summons the
monitor who takes her into the afterlife
to be with Oliver again so just more
evidence that he dies during crisis on
Infinite Earths but just remembered that
the afterlife in the DC comic book
universe is different from the afterlife
in other TV show universes so just
because he dies during the crossover
doesn't mean that other
alternate-universe versions of oliver
can't come back so stephen amell can
guest star in future crossovers or they
could always bring back force ghosts
oliver during future crossovers to be
part of whatever they do in future
seasons as long as the arrow verse
continues to be a thing think of him as
the Yoda of the arrow verse going
forward ah young Skywalker Barry Allen
how I have missed you there was a
legends of tomorrow scene where the
monitor shows up in the background he
doesn't do anything he's just sitting
there watching their show eating some
popcorn with the book of destiny to
remind you who he is and that he was a
big part of the crossover last year
because last year legends did not do the
crossover they made a joke about that
during the legends finale but he didn't
really have any big scene during the
legends episode so don't worry about
that but the legends will be part of
crisis on Infinite Earths remember
they're doing a five-part crossover so
it's all 5 shows it's flash arrow
legends of tomorrow
Supergirl in the Batwoman TV show don't
really know what that woman is gonna be
doing during the crossover we'll find
out about that later this year the
Supergirl post-credit scene is a little
more interesting because it's the
monitor collecting a couple of really
big powerful villains and it seems like
he's either gonna make them work with
the heroes to save the multiverse or if
this is a different version of the
monitor a rogue monitor and he's working
against the multiverse then he's using
them to destroy it or do something crazy
but it seems like unless we get some
more information that it's the same
monitor and he's gonna make them work
with the heroes even if you're not sure
who Martian Manhunter 'he's evil brother
is you probably picked up from this
scene that he's coming for him to get
revenge for locking him up for all these
years if you're not a big comic book
reader Martian Manhunter has an evil
brother named Mahalo Fock who tried to
release this really crazy bio agent
harming a whole bunch of their people
Martian Manhunter defeated him and
locked him up in an interdimensional
prison so the monitor using his crazy
level of power is releasing him saying I
need you to get revenge on your brother
but it also probably need him to do
something as part of this big crisis
crossover - part of the reason for doing
that I think from a story perspective is
is because Martian Manhunter as a
character is so overpowered that he
becomes a big problem for stories
because he's basically as strong as
Supergirl but he can also phase
everything and he's telepathic and he's
ancient so he has way more fighting in
battle experience than someone say like
Supergirl who's also super powerful but
you need somebody who's capable of
fighting Martian Manhunter who has
abilities that are powerful as his so
that's really why you bring in an evil
brother who has the exact same abilities
reverse-flash kind of seems like he's
his own agent of chaos in all this
obviously he's just trying to manipulate
things to his own benefit
it was the teaser in Nora's future
newspaper that says reverse-flash
leading army of shadow demons a lot of
people are like are those time rays
those are the shadow demons that are
referred to in the newspaper that's
always possible that that's who they are
but because they're changing so much
from the comics about crisis on Infinite
Earths it's hard to say whether or not
the anti-monitor will be the real main
villain or if it will be some other
person because you remember the monitors
are basically God's perspective to the
other characters in the DC Universe so
don't forget that there are many
monitors living in the multiverse the
one that we've been seeing is just one
of them so it's possible that we see
some of the other monitors flying around
but I'm guessing that for the most part
we'll just be following this one what'll
probably happen is is that when they do
the Comic Con trailers for all the TV
shows like the flash Comic Con trailer
the arrow final season Comic Con trailer
they'll have some way of teasing crisis
on Infinite Earths during those because
they're spending so much time building
up to this huge huge crossover I'm not
really planning on doing Batwoman videos
this fall for that TV show I'll be doing
Titans videos and if you're a big Batman
fan you'd rather see Batman than see bat
woman he's gonna be on Titan season -
played by Jorah Mormont's from Game of
Thrones
but Bab woman is going to be airing
back-to-back with Supergirl on Sunday
nights
so if you're a Supergirl person and you
really like that show they're making bat
woman for you but my Sunday night show
this fall starting in November is
basically going to be Rick and Morty's
season 4 so I'll be busy doing videos
for that instead of doing bat woman
videos I feel like everybody will
probably be ok with that we also have
the Star Wars Mandalorian TV series The
Witcher Netflix TV series in a whole
bunch of other really big stuff that's
starting later this year the Disney Plus
streaming service so I'll just remind
everyone when they drop footage no
worries there's a lot of really cool
stuff coming up while you wait for
everything click here for all my
Avengers endgame Easter eggs
spider-man far from home trailer videos
and click here for my Game of Thrones
finale video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]